ceausescus und willkommen zu einer neuen
folge der astor und heute spielen wieder
bett kriege mit dem erfahrenen bett
kriegen wir machen alle und so weiter am
nachmittag dann erst mal bevor
genau das will ich auch ganz fragen soll
ich lieber aber wieder zweigeteilten
kann man mit liebe im mantel
ja der ist von burberry dann alter wie
präzise die blöcke treffen jetzt gerade
nicht mit diesem für mehrere schlüssel
abgeben denn hier also von mir gebe
sorry da ist aber so ein grüner auf dem
mittleren base nein doch nicht weil ich
enttäuscht aber hinten rechts euch als
erstes team grün die sind direkt mit dem
hersteller die kriegen wir kommen zurück
skateboard das wetter so mittlerweile
das ist schon richtig stellen
ich bin schon ein kleiner schlawiner
geworden jaja dahin leute ja sehen wir
es da hinten ist der kleine mann
der kleine morfill und weiß was ich
mache ich mache jetzt einfach mal mit
ich mache jetzt erstmal den alpen mit
dem bargeld ab ja genau so viel glück
wie du ich hab ihm rückwärts laufen
musste muss man sagst du wir wählen wenn
du gerade aus auf einen ständer auf
rückwärts wenn du gerade aus bisher
weigern dann fangen die irgendwann
andere behindert zur seite zu springen
weil ihr euch seitlich unter noch wollen
und ok ok ok ich hab' rausgehauen
dass das wird ein neuer rekord etat der
rekord an ich habe mir aber richtig
lagert was die aber wiederum nicht
wissen ich habe nur zwei herzen team
blau hat einen bogen
ok einer von keen games raus ins bett
hast du auch mal sowas gelb ist weg
dann fehlten von blau weiß ich finde das
ist echt richtig speedy gründen wir
werden das genauso dafür wie ich jetzt
ist weil das ist das ungefähr die
kürzeste aufnahme aber wir schauen mal
wie lange es dauert hey hey wir machen
jetzt kaputt kommt was du hast du
blackies alte rot ist aber die busfahrer
so kann man nur spiele man die farbe rot
hat ist einfach so wall street wie viel
kostet nochmal eine ändert werde 3m
bogen vom hat den bogen an
jetzt macht das macht unsere und seinen
gottgleichen die gezogen wirklich heiße
martin bist du zunichte arbeit wird der
firma jetzt eigentlich schon was
gewonnen
ich kann jetzt bögen wieder krieg kann
man nichts machen auf meinem blog
da nimmt die reinen doch ziemlich
auseinander hast du auch einen bogen
ja ich nehme ich habe keinen hunger
bisschen gold dass damit ein paar bilden
haben die muss man melden
ohne papa ich brauche ja irgendwie
schwert hätte dann würde ich den
strecken können das ist schön
ich war glaube ich auch gerade
abgeschlossenen stammten diese vom
symbole richtig deute die da gerade
vorbei geflogen sind
diese zeichen der dunkelheit
ok doppel 5 das ist natürlich nicht die
schnellste aber sieht cool aus
25 und wenige minuten zuvor zwei okay
dann ist es wieder für das wollen wir
gleich wieder super
ich hab mal acht blöcke komme sofort
bereit um sofort herrichten schneller
besser ja ich war doch gar keine eile so
lange nicht mehr mit connected sind ja
aber konzentrieren so leicht reden macht
mich ganz ganz kind und mit einem busch
ok sah meine schuldig halte und die
stars auskommt als uns stranger
der ist weg wir sind im blauen kann ich
mal hat diesen roten darunter
ich habe um einheitlich gelten können
das mache ich also erstmal betten bauen
und dann gelb hat auch noch nicht
eingebaut dass ich mich in der sich
rechtzeitig aggressionen
das klingt richtig gut gegessen haben
wir den typen hier unter den angie boss
futter locken der mir mehr und noch gibt
mit seiner pace hat sich mit dem stock
kommt achtung das ist normal diese
schöne momente in bedburg mit dem
verdammten fix vergeben als er ihn mit
dem stock aber lexikon wunderschön des
wk 4 gold hat ärgerliche folgen wir
jetzt gerade die post auf uns
einprasseln wir gucken einfach wie die
sich dieses findet schnell könne
münchen entwickelt und ich weiß was ich
mir erst ein spitzen stock und rasch auf
welches team auch immer mir gesagt geht
sack 12 und jule hat nicht ganz so knapp
ist da vorne hoch warum nicht
alter selbst schultern die welt wenn die
uns so erschrecken wollen
ja du brauchst du erst mal nichts ab
kollege weg mit dir warum kriegt warum
ich verstehe es nicht leute die geben
mir mit der fucking pigs mehr noch
besser als ich mit diesem blöden stick
kann mir das mal jemand erklären weil
ich fürchte ich versteh's nicht so weit
mit ihr onkel onkel wunderschön aber ich
habe auch die tiebreaks modus leute es
einfach erbärmlich range ab und da habe
ich mir gedacht das ist eigentlich der
terex modus eigentlich ist genau das
wunderschöne mit der metapher tiebreaks
modus geschrieben dass er noch
vorstellen wir sind relativ wächst so
seine gegner hätten werde so geht es mir
mit meiner range nicht wirklich ein
schlechter mensch also manchmal so zwei
blöcke entspannt allein 53
das hört sich fast schon schottischen
leiter die schotten reden genau so eine
neue mitbewohner hat im schottischen
schaden
grün ist alles auch schon ohne leben
mittlerweile denn die mehr grün ist raus
alter wie viel gold so groß ist auch
zerstört nur noch blut da müssen wir
aufpassen
die wir jetzt hier zu unserem blog ja
ich weiß wie wir müssen wir aufpassen
wie wir die letzten sind dass wir ein
beliebtes ja ja klar
ich sag doch die wunde hat die wollen
dann direkt zu uns waschen so wie die
wunderschöne range eines escort kombi
partikel- und kenne ich nur kurz aus der
welt boxen kann ich und hatte gold dabei
und der hatte wollte dabei und damit ist
gelb auch raus 3 wallrother team red
river vernichtet moment mal erlebt
dennoch 8
er ist der letzte von gelb also momentan
sind wir sehr gut in der zeit
unser bett ist noch beschützt oh da ist
der gelbe richtig okay nicht richtig
wirst du am ural brüstung und bogen der
ein bisschen zu versuchen
warum kein bett mehr oder doch mehr laut
verdi noch 11 deswegen sage ich muss ja
nur irgendwo unterkommt und webber
der atx atx kannst du ja da kann ich ihm
bitte unterhalten und ich liebe diese
frau gleich gewonnen hatte lag da kommen
machen sie den kapitalmärkten du könnte
die bislang den aber ich habe keine
rüstung keiner er das bisschen ärgerlich
bisschen bisschen gold selben von er
also ich ein bisschen gold aus dem 850
holz
okay das war es ab heute man sich
gefallen das gerne einen daumen nach
oben da oder es war allgemein ein bewerb
sind der ultimative bett lag ist wieder
hier keine ahnung warum
und übrigens ich finde auch dass gott
ihm sollte mal möglich machen dass man
vor so dass man forschen kann wie groß
die runden sind weil dann kann man
wieder aufnehmen muss jetzt gerade zwei
stunden rumprobieren oder so kein halt
schon okay eine stunde aber ein heim was
schon bis es dann geschafft hatten aber
jetzt haben wir das hinbekommen und ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wir sehen uns dann in der nächsten folge
weder was gut 30
arbeit